hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
instructive game to share with you from
this is only a 24 move game a rapid game
between Gary Kasparov on the white end
and Nigel short
a couple lessons from this one
one positional in nature and another is
this very nice tactical idea
so on board French defense tarash
variation
open tarash
Knight gf3 Knight F6 and it's official
we have this Alpha zero Pawn present
space invader Pawn drives the Knight
back and white is there in time with C3
to control the Knight to maintain a Pawn
on D4 this guy doesn't have any good
forward moves now
from here B6 so this is the positional
lesson to really take away from this
game and it occurs on the queen side we
have a battle of ideas with whites with
blacks move here and White's reply to it
let's see first of all what Black's idea
is with B6
he's looking to pursue a light Square
Bishop exchange he's trying to exchange
his bad Bishop for White's good Bishop
okay sensible enough let's see White's
reply though he puts the bishop on B5 so
let me ask you what do you think the
Deep idea is behind White's last move
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video maybe give it 30 seconds see what
you come up with
okay I'm not going to share what that
deep idea is just yet we're going to get
to that soon enough
first let's get a few more developing
moves in Bishop E7 both sides castle
some room for the queen Knight many of
White's moves in this game are looking
to improve this queen Knight
A5 Knight F1 Bishop A6 one more pop quiz
here
what is White's reply to this last move
feel free to pause the video
okay move played
A4 this is the Deep idea behind Bishop
to B5 white it was anticipating Bishop
A6 would be played and he wants to be in
this spot to reinforce the B5 point with
a pawn
basically white knows
he can't prevent the light Square Bishop
exchange if black really wants to get
that in
he's going to get that in but what white
is saying is if you pursue the bad for
good Bishop exchange there will be a
cost
what is that cost let's see
Bishop takes Bishop Pawn takes Bishop
this is the cost
it is completely dominated Now by a pawn
this Knight here
dominated by upon as well
there is a serious space disadvantage
for black this is a superior structure
for white
for the remainder of the game black is
only playing on three ranks whereas
black irks me whereas white has fun on
the remainder of the ranks
a problem here for black
these two pawns are very invasive Pawn
on B5 and E5
okay we have some play on the king side
now we have a square
produced for this night so that this guy
on B8 finally has a square
okay Knight G3 black underdevelops so
that the other guy could develop
meanwhile look at the progress white has
made with this queen Knight
it is now a star piece in the game
observing F6 it's coordinated very well
with the pawn and it puts pressure on
the heart of the king side structure
that panel frequently describe as the
two-point Pawn
okay from here G3 small improvements on
the king side Knight G6 H4
and now Knight D to B8 so in the
computer's eyes this is a step in the
wrong direction
what it is a fan of instead of this move
is the capture on D4 followed up with
Queen C7 and some play on the C file
black would really like to get the
Queens off in this position
because
There's Something Brewing on the king's
side with this Knight on H5
intersection Square on F6
okay
black doesn't continue in this way
he puts the other Knight on Fe
King G2 this is healthy you'd prefer to
be on the second rank then first a light
square instead of a dark Square
and there are also these ideas now of
Rook H1 in some cases there can be
something exciting happening on the H
file
from here it's Queen D7 this move has an
eye on B5 but it's a big blunder
Can you spot why
is White's reply here
feel free to pause the video
okay
this is a bolt out of the blue
Bishop H6
What's Happening Here White's trying to
Simply make the G Pawn
Flinch he doesn't need
to capture that pawn he just wants it to
move he wants it to capture for what
reason two reasons
F6 becomes a hole and H6 becomes a whole
if this guy isn't here and he's willing
to give up a full piece in order to gain
access to these two points F6 and the H6
Square
Pawn takes Bishop in the game and now we
have Queen D2 I'd like to point out also
that this move right here Knight takes
pun may have tempted many players myself
included
it is the two point Pawn there is this
idea to next follow-up with H5 this is a
Way Forward
it still likes this position for white
here's a way to look at it though
you have this option to Simply knock the
pawn right out
or influence the pawn with Bishop to H6
the move played in the game
one thing you can take into account here
is this is a best piece in the game so
maybe it's not a wise choice to give
that piece up so easily
I mean when you look at it how many
Tempe were required in order for this
Knight to arrive on H5
he had to go to D2 The Rook had to get
out of the way that's two three four
five Tempe were required for the Knight
to get to H5 maybe it's not a good idea
to give that
piece up so quickly look at all the
effort that went into establishing that
piece in Black's house
how about we get a piece that hasn't
moved yet into the mix that's what's
happening here with Bishop H6
okay let's see how play follows Pawn
takes Bishop Queen D2 there's no
stopping the queen from knifing in and
then look at how the queen and Knight
are coordinating on G7
from here F5
trying to defend these squares
now the pawn is out of the way
but white can simply take on passan
Bishop backs off
Queen takes Pawn what do you do
there's no good answer at this stage
Rook A7 Knight G5
this is right around the corner and
there's really nothing you can do about
it
the move played in the game is Queen
takes B5
if you try to put the knight in the
corner I mean you're better off just
resigning instead of putting the knight
in the corner but this wouldn't even be
a help because F7 can still be played
Knight takes Pawn is met with mate
so there's just no defense here Queen
takes B5 we continue with F6
Rook takes F6 otherwise it would have
been mate
Knight takes Rook
this game goes no further
black resigns
he's up the white is up the exchange now
and this Knight can't be captured
if you take the Knight it's going to be
me there's no way forward here for black
so a very nice game two
nice little lessons here one positional
on the queen side and of course this
awesome bolt out of the blue with Bishop
to H6
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye